2011 the year of the fighting games
[Music]
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 bout time alright so
everyone loves crossover fighting games
and in the mid-90s Marvel vs. Capcom 2
was the king of crossover fighting games
and whom I did not review the sequel to
the king first of the fighting system
and Marvel vs. Capcom 3 is pretty easy
actually
you have three buttons low attack medium
attack heart attack and a heart attack
then a one button special attack by
pushing down over or down back and one
of the other three attack buttons will
probably pull off a special move and
there are some other attack combinations
that you learn as you play I mean that's
a learning curve part but after that
donut's beats amass and when you're
picking your character you can pick
normal mode or simple mode simple mode
might as well be called not as many
moves mode don't pick that like not ever
it's kind of like a bicycle is more
simple than a motorcycle yeah it's
easier to just pick up and go right away
but I mean seriously it's a motorcycle
just like it's normal mode do you normal
mode and it has the basic Capcom fighter
mechanics built up your meter you can do
a special move builds it up three times
over you can have all of your characters
just do an onslaught gangbang of special
moves against your opponent this game is
messed up fast err juggles special moves
air juggles and special moves in the air
attack after attack after attack no one
gets the chance to breathe in this game
which can be a little frustrating if
you're a novice but again learning curve
but in that it's also a lot like Marvel
vs. Capcom 2 so if you're a returning
fan right at home and in that it's also
really fun to watch me watching someone
play games like the dumbest thing ever
you're like why am I here right now well
watching someone play Marvel vs. Capcom
3 it can be really entertaining I like
the characters they have in Marvel vs.
Capcom but I wouldn't like to have seen
some more like Galactus is the main bad
guy where Silver Surfer and juggernaut
snot in it and people will that
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 doesn't have as many
characters as two had but two had like
regular Wolverine and bone claw
Wolverine II don't need both but this is
2011 which means three words DLC or
three letters rather downloadable
content I'm sure more characters are on
their way so the characters are pretty
well balanced I mean some hit harder
than others hulk hits like a tank but
most of them are pretty usable most of
them and i do wish the endings were you
know worth it what is it with fighting
games putting you through the biggest
grind ever and the endings are like two
pictures and three lines come on dude
and the online modes pretty solid it's
not as deep as Super Street Fighter
it's not as many options but I mean I
have dick internet a dick internet I
never got kicked off I guess that's
really a review on the PlayStation
network's aspect of it I'd like to think
it's for Marvel vs. Capcom 3 though in
the end it's really fast-paced the moves
are actually pretty easy to do the
characters are cool with hopefully some
more to come
Morgan's hot so there is that it does
have a bit of a learning curve which is
pretty frustrating if you're a novice I
give it a couple hours you'll be thrown
down a beatin ass this is a fun game if
you're a fighting game fan get it
Throwdown with your friends months of
entertainment I am a hardcore Mortal
Kombat fan but at this point Mortal
Kombat's got some competition just
saying just being fair and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more 9
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 Oh game over couldn't
handle it I understand better luck next
time
why do Capcom fighter announcement
voices sound like this like they just
brought the beer to the Jersey Shore
that's really weird
[Music]